Okay, so...
I just got Chica back from the vet...
Uhmm...
She's not having a good time right now
She is very upset with me.
Um...
She's just generally not having a good time.
She's also quite high on painkillers, as far as I'm told.
Um...
And she's just the sweetest puppy but...
She's not having a good time right now. :'(
I feel so bad!
Chica, it's okay. :(
It's alright.
It's gonna be okay. :(
She's been bonking around a lot with that cone on her head.
But she's generally okay, so she's gonna be okay.
You're okay, Chickie.
You're okay. :(
Good girl. :(
*sniffle laughs*
She's so mad at me! *Chica smiles*
She's so mad at me.
*sniffs*
You guys, it may not be easy to tell, but I know she's mad at me.
*impersonates Chica* How could you betray me and take me to that horrible place where the doctors cut me open?!
*impersonates Chica* It was BAD!
(Markiplier) *kisses*
*Chica Denys His Love*
I feel... incredibly BAD for Chica.
She uh... she keeps moving about five (5) feet... and then stopping completely and not going anywhere.
I'm trying to get her to go outside as desperately as I can.
And she's making it, but the progress is sloowww!
So...
Chica!
Come on... Come on, Chica!
You wanna... you wanna go outside Chica?
Chica wanna go outside?
Who's a puppy-wuppy? Who's a puppy-wuppy-boop?
Who's a puppy-wuppy-wuppy? Who's a puppy-pup?
Who's a puppy-puppy-puppy-poopy-puppy-pup?
Who's a puppy-pup? Who's a pup-py-pup?
She will NEVER trust me again.
She will literally shit... over everything... I have ever loved.
I can't take credit for that. My friend told me that.
Okay. So, I've officially given up on trying to get her to go outside 'cause she hasn't moved.
So, I'm trying now to get her to come up the stairs to her doggy bed in my room because that's where she's gonna be most comfortable.
And that's where I can look after her.
Unfortunately...
She hasn't moved from her spot in like, fifteen (15) minutes.
Chica!
Ohp, little response!
Chica CHICA!
Chica-bica-bica?
*harsh falsetto* mmchiCAAAAAAA!
Chicuh?
Chica, you wanna come up staaiiirs?
*melodic baritone* chiCUHHH!
*harsh falsetto again* chiCAAAA
*pats leg* Come on, puppy!
Come one, puppy. Who's a pupzy-wubzy?
Who's a bubzy-wubzy? Who's a pupzy-wubzy-chica-bica-oocha-pica?
Who's a chicapicapickapeckofpuppyboooooooooo?
You wanna come upstairs, puppy-boo?
You wanna come upstairs, chunka-bunka?
You wanna come upstairs? *pats leg*
Chica, wanna come up stairs?
You turned your head a little bit, that's progress! :)
That's what I call progress. :D
*sighs* Okay.
So, as you may be able to see, I'm not a hundred (100) percent sure but...
I had to carry her upstairs, but she is here.
She kind of conked out pretty immediately... in her little bed.
Umm... the poor girl is going to be recovering for a while.
Tomorrow she should pick up a little more energy.
Umm... I'm tired myself so I'm probably going to go to bed soon.
Even though it's still daylight out, but whatever.
I didn't get much sleep last night 'cause we were filming the, uhh...
Five Nights at Freddy's Musical. Night four (4) and five (5).
So, a lot of cool stuff coming with that very soon but...
Poor little girl here...
She's in for a rough day.
But it needed to be done.
I'm sorry, Chica.
Okay. So, I just woke up. I'm checking on Chica, and she seems to be in a little better spirits today.
Umm, a little more pep, but I do gotta give her her pain medication first thing in the morning today.
Umm, and then I'm gonna be watching over her most of the day, so...
Uhh, if you guys are seeing this...
I'm just gonna try to be a good dad today and take care of her and make sure that she's doing okay and got everything that she needs...
And I'm gonna be making sure she doesn't rip out her stitches or anything like that so...
Chica, you ready to go - oh! You can't climb in my lap with that thing.
Hey, Ch- uhoh.
Heh
Aw! Awhuh! *spits*
She's killing me with the end!
Hey, Chica-bica.
It's okay.
She likes to try to hold my hand so... she'll lift her paw up like... weirdly. You can't see.
Awuhuh!
*garbles nonsense*
But wish Chica a good recovery. She's trying to hold my hand.
She - she always gets very...
You know, T-Rex paw.
You want to hold my hand? There we go.
So... anyway...
wish her good luck recovering.
And she's gonna need it, but she's doing okay 'cause she's a good bub.
And this good bub is going to last a whiillle so...
She will survive.
Just a good bub. Say goodbye to the camera.
Bye, guys. See you tomorrow! *kiss*